so if you're gonna go into the world of
paid advertising that's a huge world and
there's so much to learn there and if
you're on a budget the key is always
targeting targeting targeting so you
need to figure out who your best user is
so if you're selling the software for
businesses what kind of business is it
how big are they how many employees do
they have in what vertical do the upper
do they operate who's going to be that
exact client it's gonna make the most
out of what I'm offering them and you
want to target those guys because you
can't afford to spend money broadly and
once you have it you know try it with a
little bit it just spend a little bit of
money and see what you get and optimize
optimize optimize and then you'll
potentially be able to get some clients
that that will use your product when you
do paid advertising what you really want
to do is experiment experiment
experiments if you have a thousand bucks
you want to run 100 experiments for ten
dollars each try different language try
different imagery try different types of
targeting what you really want to do
with that kind of budget is not get as
many users as possible it's just learn
learn what works learn what people what
what are the words what what are the
things that will get people to sign up
and out of those hundred experiments you
will see the one that works better and
later on when you have budget you'll
know how to spend it so platforms that
will work well for low budgets is uh is
an ever evolving thing right because new
platforms keep coming up and you kind of
have to find the right platform that's
right for your product but I think
marketers kind of have to keep their
eyes and ears open for what's the
up-and-coming platform and usually
platforms that are new and that I've
just opened up you know a couple of
years ago youtube I don't know what it
is today because I haven't used it in a
while but a couple of years ago getting
youtube views and targeting it down and
getting the right people to view your
video was really really cheap it was
just a few cents for for every video
view so that was that was YouTube and it
usually starts out when when it's new
that there's not a lot of competition so
if you're the first one there you'll get
the cheapest prices it was the same for
for facebook app install ads that was a
brilliant format and Facebook started a
few years ago and
when it just came out it was so cheap
and you could take such great advantage
of that and today you know everybody's
there so competition drives the prices
up so you kind of need to keep your eyes
open for for what's new and what's what
can you take advantage of